bienvenido a france 24 ya hay datos
suficientes y evidencias científicas
sobre los síntomas menos graves de
omikron
bueno está claro que causa menos
enfermedad severa el problema es que
como hay muchos más casos debido a su
gran capacidad de transmisión pues los
casos enfermedad severa absolutos pueden
llegar a ser muy parecidos a los que
había antes pero desde luego la
proporción de enfermedad severa que
causa un micrón es mucho menor que la
que causaban las variantes anteriores
bueno y además de lo anterior a qué
factores se debe que consideren que
consideren esta variante como algo
beneficioso para repartir inmunidad
entre la población
sí bueno estamos viendo que el virus
está cambiando como nos esperábamos
desde el punto de vista evolutivo y que
es el modo en que está cambiando es el
modo de que normalmente acaban las
pandemias las pandemias anteriores es
decir el virus se vuelve más
transmisible es capaz de infectar alguna
gran cantidad de gente las personas
adquieren inmunidad debido a esta
infección y eso da lugar también a una
disminución todavía más de la de la
capacidad de producir enfermedad lo
diferente con respecto antes pandemias
sobre todo pandemias de hace ya 50 años
es que esta vez hemos tenido una vacuna
que ha logrado disminuir el número de
muertes que podía haber causado el virus
pero seguramente un micro 11a ya la
última parte que tenemos la pandemia y
una vez que pase omicron el virus se
quedará con nosotros pero ya no causará
tantos casos tantos números de casos y
eso dará lugar a que se vuelva un virus
normal como otros virus respiratorios y
ateridos y con el pasar del tiempo
empezamos a escuchar un cambio en la
terminología de pandemia a endemia
porque hoy 19 qué significa esta nueva
consideración
bueno pandemia es algo que es un
acontecimiento global infeccioso que
involucra a todo el mundo y que da lugar
a una emergencia mientras que en denia
es cuando el virus existe en él
circulando a un nivel relativamente bajo
pero presente en distintos sitios y
luego epidemia que es la otra que es la
otra sección que seguramente también nos
queda el virus no sólo como endémico es
decir en distintos casos pero muy
poquitos por distintas zonas pero cómo
epidémico quiere decir que eso causará
un poco más número de casos durante las
epidemias que seguramente sean
estacionales de invierno igual que
ocurre con las epidemias de gripe o con
otras epidemias otros virus
respiratorios que suelen ser dura un
pico en invierno y por eso se llaman
epidemias por un pico que da que dar
lugar pero es un pico mucho menor que el
que dan los picos pandémicos a los que
estamos expuestos ahora bueno hace sólo
unos días científicos franceses
indicaron que identificaron una nueva
variante con 46 mutaciones frente a la
original y los expertos alertan que
seguirán presentándose si la gente no se
vacuna cómo funciona este proceso de
adaptación y cómo lo frenan las y no
acciones
si el virus siempre está mutando y el
número de mutaciones
que se presenta en el mundo depende
también de la cantidad de virus que haya
cuanto más virus haya más espectro
mutacional es decir si por ejemplo 0 1
por ciento de los virus que hay en el
mundo tiene una mutación pues si hay a
billones o trillones de virus en el
mundo pues las mutaciones que existen
presentes son mayores y eso da lugar a
una mayor variabilidad genética que hace
que el virus favorezca que pueda cambiar
adaptarse más rápidamente e incluso
poder poder evadir inmunidad
preexistente por vacuna por vacunación
es decir cuanto menos circulando haya
menos variantes va a haber que den lugar
a problemas eso no quiere decir que
desaparezcan completamente pero si
desaparecen la velocidad en que en la
que llegan así como el tiempo en que
llegan pueden aparecer variantes en
lugar de cada cuatro meses que es lo que
estamos viendo ahora mismo con este
virus pues pueden aparecer a lo mejor
cada dos años doctor garcía sastre a
usted muchísimas gracias por su análisis
y por compartirlo con nosotros en france